that which does not kill us makes us
stronger friedrich nietzsche famously
wrote
in this sprout special in collaboration
with stephen hicks we explore
nietzsche's division of the world into
sheep and wolves and how our morality
what we consider as good and bad is the
result of brute biological events
part two
sheep and wolves
nietzsche says all of organic nature is
divided into these two types of species
those who are naturally heard animals
and those who are naturally loners
those who are prey and those who are
predators
psychologically and physically this
divide also runs right through the human
species
some people are born fearful and
inclined to join a herd and some are
born fearless and inclined to seek
lonely heights
some of us are born sedentary and
sluggish and some of us are born
crackling with purpose and craving
adventure
some to use nietzsche's language are
born to be masters and some are born
slaves
there is a brute biological fact here
our traits are revolutionarily bred into
us
just as a sheep cannot help but be
sheepish and a [ __ ] cannot help but be
hawkish each of us inherits from our
parents a long line of in-built traits
the master types live by strength
creativity and independence they respect
power courage risk-taking even
recklessness
it is natural for them to follow their
own path no matter what to rebel against
social pressure and conformity
[Music]
and by contrast the slave types live in
conformity they tend to passivity
dependence meekness
it is natural for them to stick together
for a sense of security as heard animals
do
nietzsche then turns to morality good
and bad right and wrong
for a long time we have been taught that
morality is a matter of commandments set
in stone thousands of years ago
not so says nietzsche what we take to be
moral depends on our biological nature
and different biological natures dictate
different moral codes
think of it this way if you are a sheep
then what will seem good to you as a
sheep
being able to graze peacefully sticking
close together with others just like you
being part of the herd and not straying
off
what will seem bad to you wolves will
seem bad and anything wolf-like
predatory or aggressive
but what if you were a wolf
then strength viciousness and contempt
for the sheep will come naturally to you
and seem good
there is nothing the wolves and the
sheep can agree on morally their natures
are different as are their needs and
goals as is what feels good to them of
course it would be good for the sheep if
they could convince the wolves to be
more sheep-like but no self-respecting
wolf will fall for that
so
one's moral code is a function of one's
psychological makeup and one's
psychological makeup is a function of
one's biological makeup
nietzsche is among the first to apply
evolutionary concepts to morality
moral codes are part of a biological
types life strategy of survival and the
more one looks at the history of
morality evolutionarily and biologically
the more one is struck by dramatic
changes in moral codes across time
and this is the key problem nietzsche
argues for the historical record shows a
disturbing inversion
formally we prized above all excellence
and power we look down upon the humble
and the lowly
yet now the meek the humble and the
common man are the good while the
aggressive the powerful the strong the
proud are evil
somehow the morality of the weak has
become dominant and the morality of the
strong has declined
this moral inversion is dangerous the
traits of strength and power those of
that in noble man are now condemned and
the traits of ordinariness and modesty
those of that weakened man are praised
morality accordingly has become a bad
thing or more paradoxically morality has
become immoral
the morality of the weak has somehow
become dominant and the morality of the
strong has declined
how is this rather paradoxical state of
affairs to be explained
to be continued
[Music]
what are your thoughts on nietzsche's
view of man being born along the
spectrum of sheep and wolves and do you
share his concern about an inversion of
moral values
for more information check the
descriptions below there you'll also
find a link to stephen hicks full
account of the german philosopher
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts